Would you trust a religion with a
corrupted scripture?
>> Can you explain to me scriptures that's
wrong about it?
>> If there were scriptures within a
religion that have been altered and
changed and messed with, would that
religion be trustworthy still?
>> Well, hasn't the Bible been corrupt,
too?
>> Are you going to answer the question or
>> Oh, well, bro, the Bible for me
personally,
>> the Bible, the Bible, the Bible, the
Bible, the Bible. Squirrel. That's what
you guys sound like when I ask a direct
question and you guys completely get
distracted and shift somewhere.
>> And I think
>> I never said that. Did I Did you hear me
say anything about the Quran, my
brother?
>> Oh, basically you're saying Islam is
untrustworthy. Do you even know what
Islam means?
>> Did I say anything?
>> Notice this. This is another thing. You
you still have are incapable of
answering a straight word means then we
can't continue the conversation. What
does mean?
>> I'm I'm not going to lie to you, man.
I'm going to need you to educate
>> before you debate. Be responsible first
and be sure you know about a religion
for
you're not responsible
not even know do you mind educating me?
Do you mind educating me? I'm a humble
guy. I don't care. Why don't you go read
a book? You have intelligence. Right.
You can go do it yourself. I'm not going
to give you the answer. Go read the
book. Can I can I read Can I read this?
>> I'm done with this conversation.
>> Can I read this or can I read this?
Which one should I be responsible for
you starting another?
>> Can I read this or this? Or maybe I
don't know. Maybe I should read this.
Should I read? Which one of these should
I read to know what the word Islam
means? Matter of fact, hold on. Or maybe
this one. Maybe I should read this one.
Which one should I
>> give me the definition? Just show me.
Show me.
>> Which one should I read to learn the
definition?
>> Damn you, please.
>> Which of these? Which of these Qurans
will tell me the mean the definition of
Islam? Which one?
>> I want to hear it out of your own words
and see.
>> What do you mean out of my own words?
You told me to read a book.
>> Yeah, let me see it out of your own
mouth. You told me to read a book. Hey,
life. Didn't he tell me to read a book?
>> You sure did. Look like you got four.
Look like look like Look like you got
four of them up there, man.
>> Four of them up here, man.
>> What's the point of having as you must
have some type of belief book?
>> All these four books. Which one tells me
which one? Which one tells me about
Islam? Which one, man? I'm trying to
learn. I'm trying to be responsible.
>> F.
>> Oh, I said responsible, bro. Now you're
trying. Now, now you trying to make it
seem like I said other things, bro.
>> Now you're trying. Now, now you first
off, bro, you don't really know the
religion. I
>> about something that you don't know
about and you're responsible. Is that
right? I'm saying I'm not going to talk
about something I'm not because that
makes me be an individual and not
responsible or me talking to myself I
don't know about. And look at you being
a clown, bro. This ain't that trying to
make it a comedy show and everything,
bro. Anyways, bro, to
>> just said Muhammad Allah. All that all
that crime.
>> All that crime. You know, we we was
waiting for this major. We were waiting
on you, man. We in the We were looking
for a reason
>> to to bring out the violin. And this maj
behavior, this daily prayer behavior,
bro.
>> Five daily. Five dailies, man. That's
what they do to you, man.
>> Don't cry, baby. [music]
Baby, you'll be okay. Okay. Don't cry,
baby. Wipe those [music] tears away. I
know it hurts to be wrong every day.
Wow. Wow. That's all [music] you got to
say.
Stop lying. Stop crying. Stop whining.
You got me dying. Stop [music] crying.
Stop crying.
Stop crying. [music]
>> Stop all that crying, man. Quit all that
crying. that all day, man. That all day.
>> Look at all that crying, man. Listen
here. If y'all going to come up here
crying, man, you going to get
humiliated. I'm just letting you know
that right now, man. Letting you know
that right now, ma'am. Shoot. I just
want to know which one of those Qurans
gives me the definition of Islam.
[laughter]
[gasps] I'm trying to be responsible,
man. I'm trying to read. I'm trying to
Hey, look. He said
>> they still complain. He said, "Ikra,
man." Ikra, which one? Which one, man?
[laughter]
He said, "Ma," Oh, shoot. Alhamdulillah.
Muhammad Allah. That's what he said.
Muhammad Allah. Muhammad Allah.
>> What's up, Fak? How's it going?
>> Yeah, man. What's up?
>> What's up, man? Uh, would you believe in
a religion with corrupted scripture?
>> No, of course.
>> No, you said no. Of course.
>> Of course not. How is Islam and
trustworthy, man?
>> Yeah. So, we got to go through the line
of questioning first. So you wouldn't
believe in a religion full of corrupted
scripture. Therefore,
>> no, I want to address the prompt. There
are prompts say Islam is untra. I want
you to tell me how it's untrouble.
>> Okay. All right. Now, you got to listen
to the line of questioning that's going
to prove that Islam is untrustworthy.
You get the
>> line of questioning.
>> Yeah. The line of questioning would
prove Islam is untrustworthy. Can you
get that? You understand that?
>> Question one.
>> Thank you. Question one, you already
answered it. You wouldn't follow a
religion with corrupted scripture,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So if you wouldn't follow a
religion with corrupted scripture, why?
>> Because Yeah, definitely. You might not
be following the information from God or
revelation from God's been tampered
with,
>> right? Exactly. You might not be
following the truth, right? It's altered
some, you know, you just can't can't
figure it out, right? It's not it's just
not true. The word of God has been
altered. Can't trust it. All right.
Cool. Sure.
>> So, of all the scriptures revealed in
your in your religion, how many of them
were corrupted and how many of them were
preserved? Not only Quran has been
revealed to me.
>> Yeah. I'm I'm asking you out of all of
the scriptures in your religion. You
have more scriptures, more revelation
that was revealed in your religion. How
many of those are corrupt? Yeah. How
many of those? Yeah. In your religion,
how many of those are corrupted? And how
many of those are preserved?
>> Yeah. I have Quran that is preserved.
>> So everything else is not preserved.
>> Yeah. Because it was put up on the the
people at the time to preserve it
>> and they didn't preserve it. So they
corrupted it.
>> Yeah. So I'm not a follower of all those
scripture follower of the scripture
Quran which contain all the whole
contain the information of the the
information in all the previous
scriptures. No, there's no issue of
that.
>> Right. So those were Allah's Islamic
scriptures, right?
>> Come again.
>> Those were Allah's Islamic scriptures.
Correct.
>> What do you mean by Islamic scripture?
>> Okay. Meaning that under the religion of
Islam, there's a set of scriptures
revealed by your God.
>> Yeah. At that particular point of of
time. Yeah.
>> Right. And uh those scriptures got
corrupted.
>> Yeah. Because it wasn't meant for
eternity.
>> It doesn't matter what it was meant for
at this moment.
>> Yeah. That is the point. It wasn't meant
for eternity.
>> That is the point. Well, don't worry
about it. Don't Don't worry about it. I
don't worry about it. I'll cook you on
that in a second. So that you do admit
that all of the scriptures that your God
revealed were corrupted except for the
Quran.
>> Yeah. Because the the one that was
corrupted wasn't meant for eternity.
Quran is meant for eternity. That's why
it can't be corrupted. God God took it
upon himself to preserve it because it
is identity.
>> Nice. So within your religion, the
majority of your scriptures are
corrupted. No, you are presupposing that
in jail the previous scripture is within
my my my my I'm not I'm not obliged to
follow it.
>> But it's within your religion though,
right?
>> I'm not obliged to follow.
>> You are. You are. You are. We'll figure
that out in a second. I just want to
know if these are scriptures are within
Islam. Are these Islamic scriptures?
>> What do you again? I ask what do you
mean by Islamic scripture?
>> Scriptures revealed by your God.
>> Yes.
>> Thank you. So these are Islamic
scriptures.
>> It doesn't It doesn't necessarily mean
that we today we've underproof.
>> It's not about following it at the
moment. It's not about following it at
the moment. You said that you're you
said that you wouldn't follow a religion
>> with corrupted scripture. Yet you're
admitting that all of the scriptures in
your religion are corrupted except for
the Quran. So we need to get past this
before I start to tell you what your
Quran says about these books.
>> Again, you want us to still go go in a
circle, bro? I I just told you that
could because the previous scripture
wasn't meant for eternity. That's why
Allah could allow the people to tamper
with because it's meant for eternity.
Allah took him upon himself to preserve
it for because it is
>> okay. So we'll get to that after this. I
just want you to I just want you to
acknowledge
>> is
>> we'll get to that. We'll get to that in
a minute. I want you to acknowledge that
all of the scriptures in Islam are
corrupted except for the Quran. I just
want you to acknowledge that you you're
telling me you don't have to follow it.
That's fine. We'll deal with that in a
second. Do you agree that all of the
scriptures revealed in your religion are
all corrupted except for your Quran?
>> No, I don't accept that premise.
>> Okay. So, show me the uncorrupted
scriptures that's not the Quran.
>> No, I don't accept that premise that you
are using. Yes. that the all the all the
religious scriptures in you
>> what what look look what scriptures look
listen pay attention pay attention
>> out of all listen listen out of all of
the out of all of the scriptures pay
attention bro because if you don't agree
with everything that I say you shouldn't
be talking it's my turn listen out of
all of the scriptures that has been
revealed in your religion which ones
were what do you mean you disagree I
didn't even finish the question out of
all of Pay attention Pay attention. Out
of all of the scriptures your God
revealed to mankind, which ones were
preserved and which ones were corrupted?
>> Good. Now you ask that's a good
question. Yeah. [laughter] Quran is the
only religious scripture that is being
preserved. Yeah.
>> Okay. So if the Quran is the only
religious scriptures that was preserved
in your religion, all of the other ones
were corrupted.
>> No. No. You're conflicting again. In my
religion is different from to mankind.
>> Welcome to Islam, ladies and gentlemen.
>> Oh my gosh. How many scriptures were
revealed in your religion? Sir,
>> this is why I like
>> just the Quran.
>> How many religious scriptures were
revealed to man?
>> How many scriptures? Don't say don't say
religious scriptures. How many
scriptures did your God reveal to
mankind other than the Quran? Don't
mention the Quran. What other scriptures
did your God reveal?
>> Yeah, a lot. Not only one.
>> Okay. Did any of them get preserved or
were they all corrupted?
>> No, it wasn't preserved.
>> Thank you. So all of the other
scriptures Wait, wait. So conclusion,
>> that doesn't change nothing.
Okay. So then answer the question
honestly. Stop trying to act like Stop
trying to act like Wait. Answer the
question honestly then. I don't care if
it doesn't matter to you.
>> So that means that all of the other Hold
on. You I need you to agree with this.
All of the other scriptures that Allah
has revealed got corrupted.
>> Yes. Because it wasn't made for the for
eternity. So what is the point?
>> Thank you. Thank you. So So the mass
majority of your scriptures revealed in
your religion have been corrupted. Thank
you. Now, I'm going to show you how your
religion makes absolutely no sense.
Since you don't know how to draw
conclusions, I'm not going to go in
circles with you. Now, in chapter 2,
verses 2 through 5, your God says that a
Muslim cannot be successful unless they
follow all of what has religion with
corrupted scripture. Would you? Is the
Torah an Islamic book?
>> He saying, Paul, don't ask me dumb
question like that.
>> Is the gospel a corrupted book? Chapter
2:es 2-5.
>> Wow. This is amazing.
>> Can you read it, please? Can you read
it?
>> It's like talking to these. It's like
talking to one of these, ain't it?
>> Yeah.
>> It's like talking to one of these.
>> Wait, I need you.
>> So, look. So, you said you said it
doesn't matter if all those books were
corrupted because they weren't for all
of mankind. All right. Well, let's see
what your God thinks. And who believe?
>> What is it? What is it? What is it?
Chapter 2. Yeah. Chapter 2:es 4-5.
>> Okay. I'm going to read this for a
second.
>> No, I'm going to read it out loud, bro.
So, it says, "And who believe in what
has been revealed to you and what was
revealed before you and have sure faith
in the hereafter." And it is, hold on,
hold on. Verse 5. And it is they who are
truly guided by the Lord. And it is they
who will be successful. So if these
books were not for all mankind
[laughter] and they were just for a
specific time period, why is Muhammad in
the seventh century telling people that
they will not be successful and
rightfully guided by Allah unless they
believe in all of those books?
>> Okay. Is belief the same as following?
>> What does it mean to believe in the
Quran?
>> Yeah. Believe that someone exists
doesn't necessarily have.
>> No, no, no. What? No. What? No. Answer
this. What does it mean to believe in
the Quran? How how can I believe in the
Quran?
>> Yeah, you believe in the Quran because
you are see and you the law is there.
You are following it. But the previous
scripture
>> No, wait, wait, wait. You just said it.
Wait, pay attention. You said I believe.
Wait, wait. Let me explain.
>> No, no, no. Pay attention to what you
just said. You said I believe in the
Quran because what it says there and I
follow it. Right.
>> Wait, wait. I I will I will take you to
another direction. When Quran says we
need to when one of our faith is to
believe in prophets, all the prophet
that exists. But is it necessary intense
that we have to follow all the pro? No.
Just affirming that exist Allah sent
them to is enough. We doesn't
necessarily need to know the information
was being sent for them or to them.
>> Brother pay attention. Pay pay
attention. Pay attention. Just answer
this and don't give me pay attention.
Just answer this and don't give me all
that.
>> Sorry you sir. I just so I don't the
next point.
>> I want you to clarify clearly. Say this
again. I don't think you heard what you
said. What does it What does it mean?
How what does it mean to believe in the
Quran? How do I believe in the Quran?
>> Yeah, because Quran is meant for
eternity and it's for me and it's for my
religion today. I have to follow every
bit and piece of what it says.
>> Thank you. Thank you. So too.
>> No, but it doesn't necessarily logically
>> I don't need the lawful sir. Give me a
second. So what it means to believe in
the Quran like he just said is to follow
it. In order to follow the Quran, I have
to know what the Quran says.
Thank you. So this verse here says,
"Believe in the Quran and what Allah has
revealed prior." Now I'm going to ask
you, Fak, what did Allah reveal? What
did Allah reveal prior to the Quran?
You're on mute. I love how when it says
believe in the Quran, they understand
you have to follow what's in the Quran.
But when they say believe in the Torah
and the Inj Oh, that just means believe
the book existed.
>> Why are you meeting me, bro? Why are you
meeting me?
>> Because I don't need I don't need you to
waffle yourself out of the conclusion. I
need to stay focused here.
>> Yeah, I just told you what it is. I said
because Quran is meant for me today and
I'm saying and it's meant for
>> We already addressed that.
>> No, I got you. We already addressed
that. Now the second point. Now the
second point,
>> right? The second point.
>> Second part. I'm asking the second part.
You need to chill, man.
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> I just need to affirm that Allah send
the pro previous prophet with previous
book. That is enough. I just I don't
need
>> I'm not asking you what is enough.
>> Yes, this is what I need. I'm not asking
you what is enough. I'm asking you when
the verse says and what was revealed
before you, what is it referring to in
verse four. When it says believe in
something that was revealed before you.
What's he referring to?
>> Yeah. Because it's compared for for me
as a Muslim. It's an article of faith
for me to believe. Not
>> believe. No. No. It says believe in. No,
it says believe in.
>> Yeah. To believe.
>> Okay. So, what is So, what is he telling
you to believe in that came before
Muhammad?
>> What? What is he telling you to believe
in that came before Muhammad?
>> Oh my god. The previous scriptures, sir.
>> Okay. And what are the previous
scriptures?
>> There are a lot. Not only two, three,
four. There are a lot.
>> Okay. What are they? I know there are a
lot. I know there's a lot of them.
That's why the mass majority of your
religion is full of corrupted scripture.
So I'm asking you, what is he referring
to?
>> What is he telling you to believe in?
Name the scriptures.
>> So you want us to keep going a second?
>> Do you not know? Do do you not know what
do you I'm confused. Do you not know I'm
I'm confused. I'm confused. Here I'm
going to give you I'm going to give you
another verse since you you just you
just despised this book. I feel like you
only I feel like you only like No, no,
be quiet. I feel like you only like
praying and going to the masid and
feeling cool for being a Muslim. I don't
really think you like what the book
says. So here's the thing. I'm gonna
read you a verse and if you don't know
what your book is talking about, then
I'mma just kick you.
>> Chapter 4. No m. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no. You don't get to just run away from
questions and then try to ask me
something.
>> Clarify this. Please clarify this for me
before you ask me the question.
>> What am I? Okay. What What do you want
me to clarify?
>> Okay. To believe and to follow is
identical,
>> dude. to believe in.
>> Believing in a book is completely
different than saying believe the book
existed. Those are two different things.
>> No, I'm asking you a question. Is belief
and to follow identical? Sir,
>> brother, in order to believe in
somebody, you have to follow what it is
that they're saying. That means that you
follow their statements. If I believe in
Christ, that means that I'm following
what Christ taught. If I'm believing in
a book, that means I'm following what
the book taught. I can't believe in a
book without understanding what the book
says inside of it. Like, bro, this is
basic. Like, come on, dude. We're not
I'm not I'm [laughter] not about to
answer I'm not about to answer the same
question twice. I answered it already.
>> Let me read your Quran. I'm going to
read your Quran
>> to to say yes or no.
>> I'm going to believe Yes. Yes. Believing
yes. Believing in something and
following [laughter] something is the
same thing. Yes.
>> No, it's not. It's not the same.
>> Okay. All right. Cool. Chapter 4 136.
Oh, believers. Okay, fine. It could not
be the same for you. That's cool. Oh
believers, have faith in Allah, his
messengers, the book he has revealed to
his messenger. That's the Quran, right?
>> Is that the Quran?
>> Okay. Let me ask you this thing. Since
you said,
>> bro. All right. So, I see I can't answer
ask you a question. I'm going to just
read the book, make my conclusion, and
I'm going just let you say what you got
to say. We're going to drop you. Oh
believers, have faith in Allah, his
messenger, the book he has revealed to
his messenger and the scriptures he has
revealed before. Indeed, whoever denies
Allah, his angels, his books, his
messengers, and the last day has clearly
gone astray. So, you've gone astray if
you deny all of Allah's books. What
books is he referring to in chapter 4,
verse 136?
>> Okay. Can I can I speak now without any
interruption?
>> Yes. As long as you tell me what books
your God is talking about in chapter 4
136.
>> Why are you why are you negating the
part that says that we need to follow
the prophet as well?
>> I'm not.
>> No, you are.
>> Dude, the verse says follow Muhammad and
it also says follow the books that were
given to the other prophets.
>> I'm not denying that. Now what are the
other books? You see, I gave you what
you want. Now what are the other books
your God tells you to follow? I love how
you know the verse is telling you to
follow Muhammad, but somehow it you it
lo it leaves your brain when he's
telling you to follow the other books.
>> Yeah.
>> So, what other books if if if he's
telling you to follow Muhammad in the
book he has, what other books is he
telling you to follow when it says his
books plural?
>> Okay, chill. I I will answer you now. I
just I told you believe and to follow is
not identical. absolute doesn't is not
absolutely identical. According to my
article of faith, it is of large for me
to to believe in the previous prophet
and the previous books that was sent to
them. But I mustn't follow I mustn't
follow it. But what I'm obliged to
follow and believe is the last and the
final prophet and the Quran.
>> How do you how do you how do you believe
in a book if you've never read it?
>> What?
>> How do you believe in a book if you've
never read it? Can I say I believe in
the Quran without ever reading it or
seeing it? I've never read a page. I've
never Look, I'm on an island somewhere.
Somebody comes to me and shows me a
Quran and they ask me, "Do you believe
in this book?" Can I say yes if I've
never if that's the first time I've ever
seen that book? I've never read it. I
don't know what's in it. Can I say yes?
>> Ah. Oh. So, the point here now is you
before you believe something, you must
know what it is. Yes. Or you must have
seen it. Is that your point? Alive.
>> Answer the question or you're going to
get kicked, bro.
>> Life. Life. Life.
>> Answer the question or you're going to
get kicked. something to believe. Oh,
you want you know you know you want to
be back here, bro. Can you answer my
question?
>> Answer the question.
>> For you, you are presupposing that for
you to believe in something, you must
have seen and touch it or or maybe say
it, right? Is that what you mean?
>> I I don't know, man. I don't know.
>> That's why you That's why that is why
you tell me that's what you're trying to
say.
>> Yeah, that's what I'm trying to say.
That's what I'm trying to say, bro.
>> This is This is what happens in Islam,
ladies and gentlemen. you fail to
remember what it means to believe in a
book. All of a sudden, they only
understand their book when it says
believe in the Quran. Believe in the
Quran and believe in Muhammad. But
literally in the same verse, the other
books that Allah revealed are also
mentioned in what you're supposed to
believe in. When it says believe in
Muhammad, he he instantly knew. You're
skipping the part where it says follow
Muhammad. You see, I use the word
follow. Follow follow Muhammad. It's
telling you follow Muhammad and the
scriptures that are being revealed to
him. But then when it says the same
thing for the scriptures before, oh, all
of a sudden they don't know what they
book is talking about anymore, bro. They
just they it it they're confused.
They're confused, guys. So if you want
to join Islam, you want to be in a
religion where you're forced to act like
you don't know what believing in a book
means, believing in God's previous
scriptures means. When God tells you to
believe in his Torah and his injil, he
just tells you believe somebody had that
book at one point in time. Just believe
it existed in history at one time. Go
ahead, man. Enjoy Islam. That's what you
get. That's what you get when you follow
a religion. That makes no sense. It
makes you sound like that. That's that
that's that mid behavior, man.
>> Five daily.
>> Five daily, man. You know, it's crazy
because I brought my godson in here and
he was able to pay attention way better
than Fak was. I brought him in here as
an example. You do a very good job of
paying attention, buddy.
>> Yeah,
>> you really do. A lot better than these
moods. Yep. You're going to be cooking
them one day. So, be ready. He's going
to have to give him that look. Just like
that. Y'all see his poise already? his
patience. He's already already ready.
Life I have a theory. I have a theory
with with why it is that you quit. Why
you gave up?
>> Sure. What? Let's hear it.
>> My theory is this. My theory is that you
don't choose you quick enough.
>> Not really. I wouldn't say
>> you hear you hear him out for a long
time.
>> No, I wouldn't I wouldn't say I wouldn't
say that. I would [snorts] I'm I'm I'm
watching you,
>> I guess. So, maybe that lasted a little
too longer, but what's the point? What's
the point of talking to people for two
for 20 seconds? Not
>> if I really wanted him gone, the the the
moment he started acting slow, he would
have he would have been gone. Like, I
got to give him a little bit of room to
show why people shouldn't join the
religion. Like,
>> I thought hell was already established
>> at that point. Yeah.
>> Student, you're on stage.
>> Hello. Can you hear me?
>> Hi. Is it Is it okay if I use your name
on YouTube?
>> Uh, yeah, that's fine. Just please don't
say my last name if you can.
>> Okay. And you said you're Muslim?
>> Yes, sir.
>> I'll just call I'll just call you
student, bro. I won't put you.
>> That's right. That's fine with me.
>> All right. Go ahead. Like, hey, what's
up, Brandon?
>> How's it going?
>> Pretty good, man. Would you follow a
religion with corrupted scripture like
all the other Muslims?
>> I would have. I would if I was commanded
to.
>> You said you would if you were commanded
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. So, you would follow a religion.
Okay. So, what would make a religion
full of corrupted scriptures
trustworthy?
>> What is that bumping on your mic,
brother? You got you're like bumping on
your mic.
>> Oh, sorry. I'm walking around at the
moment. I'm home alone.
>> You sit down.
>> Yeah. Try try to hold your your mic or
something cuz it keeps bumping.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah. What what what would make you what
would make your religion that you follow
full of corrupted scriptures
trustworthy? So since you would follow a
religion full of corrupted scripture,
I'm going to just let you know now Islam
is full of corrupted scripture. So how
do you justify Islam being trustworthy
full when it's full of corrupted
scripture?
>> Well, it is a hard question for me to
answer, but I would say in the Quran we
believe like in the story of Genesis for
example, we believe in Adam and Eve. Uh
we believe in Noah, we believe in Moses,
we believe in Abraham and many of the
other prophets that appear in the Torah.
So to an extent, we do follow the Torah.
>> Yeah. You don't follow
>> in our own way.
>> Yeah. You don't follow the literal
Torah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We don't follow the current
literal Torah.
>> You don't follow the Torah at all
because you haven't established how you
have it and know what it taught. You
can't just One second. You can't just
say you believe in these prophets and
then say you believe in the Torah just
because you said you believe in the
prophets that are found within the
Torah. That doesn't work like that.
>> But we did. We we learned about the
prophets from the Torah. That is the
source of the prophets is the Torah.
>> Student. You're still bumping your your
mic.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah. Try try to hold it so that it's
not bump like something whatever is
bumping. You got to hold it cuz it's
>> Sorry, I'm I'm just a bit nervous.
>> Okay.
>> But yeah.
>> So yeah. So explain. Okay. So where is
the for first of all you're saying that
your religion is trustworthy when it's
full of corrupted scripture. Is that
what I'm saying? Also too, I want to say
Cal, stop acting like you can't go live,
bro. come to YouTube and join the the
join the request. I don't know why you
guys always act like you can't join. You
know where we're at. We're on YouTube,
bro. Cal, you have more you you
literally you're more than welcome to
come in here right now, bro. Like, you
guys just be playing games in the chat
like somebody running from you. Come up.
All right, student. You're saying that
your religion is full of corrupted
scripture. Your god tells you to believe
in it and therefore you believe that
it's trustworthy and true. Now, you're
gonna have to establish how we can trust
your religion because it's true and and
full of corrupted scripture. So, how is
that the case? That's what I'm asking
you, brother. You got to show me how
it's true. You can't just tell me it's
true because we believe in all the
prophets. That that that's that don't
work, bro.
>> Well, it's kind of like if I if I follow
a recipe without the book, but the
recipe is the exact same recipe that is
in the book, then essentially I am
following the book. No. How do you know
the same? How do how do you know that
recipe is in the book?
>> Well, we are taught about all the
prophets. They teach us about the
prophets. We learn about Abraham and
Moses and Noah. A lot of those stories
are in the Quran.
>> Okay. So, when you go to the previous
scriptures and you don't see a
connecting theology, then what do you
do?
>> Well, there is a connecting theology, my
friend. We have, you know, us and the
Jews, we believe in one God. Well, the
Christians obviously
I believe the Christians believe in one
God, too, to be quite honest.
>> That's fine. But that's not a connecting
theology. Just because you go and read
in another book and it says they believe
in one God, that doesn't mean that that
God is your God.
>> Well, personally, I believe that that
the the God of the Torah and the God of
the Bible is the God of the Quran.
>> Really?
>> Yes, sir.
>> I'm not a
>> So, if I prove to you that that's not
true, then then what are you going to
say?
>> All I can do is listen.
>> Okay. Is your God Yahweh?
>> Uh, yes. The short answer is yes.
>> Allah is Yahweh. Okay, cool.
>> Okay, cool. Allah is Yahweh. Did Yahweh
send his son for the salvation of
mankind?
>> Yahweh has no sons.
>> Okay, so your God is not the God of the
Bible.
>> Where does the Bible say that God sent
his son?
>> Uh yeah. First Peter 3 18. For Christ
also suffered once for sins, the
righteous for unrighteousness, that he
might bring us to God, being put to
death in the flesh, but made alive in
the spirit. John 3:16, "For God so loved
the world, he sent his only begotten
son, for that whoever believeth him have
everlasting life." Did your God do that?
>> Well, I believe no.
>> So your God is not the God of the Old
Testament, nor the New Testament, nor
the Torah, nor the angel. Cuz that's
what the angel teaches and that's what
the Old Testament is about. Yahweh and
his salvation for mankind.
>> Well, with all due respect, sir, you
know what I'm going to say? I'm going to
say that that specific Yes, that's what
that specific part was corrupted. And I
I understand that.
>> So how can I trust your religion if
every time the book that you go to to
prove your religion to be true? Whenever
you see something that makes your
religion false, you just tell me it's
all corrupted.
>> Well, it's an issue of consistenc.
It's an issue [laughter] of consistency.
Throughout the entire Old Test
throughout [clears throat] the entire
Old Testament, God never sends any sons.
He never has any wives. He never has any
equals. He only sends messengers again
and again. He only send sends messages.
>> Brother, I just gave you verses proving
what God did in that book. You don't get
to cherrypick. It's it it is what it is.
When it comes to this book now, if you
want to claim that it's corrupted and
altered simply because it differs from
what your book says, you are now in a
fallacy called cherrypicking. You have
came to this book to try to prove your
religion and then turned around and said
everything that you don't like is
corrupted because it doesn't fit with
your theological narrative. That's
>> that's not what I don't like. Sorry. I
>> you you Hold on. Let me Let me tell you
this. Your book, your prophet, your
religion needs independent verification
when it comes down to proving that
Muhammad is part of the Abrahamic faith.
You You have to have that. You can't
just
>> You can't just go back to your Quran.
Watch Watch your You're bumping your mic
again, uh, student.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like
>> it's really It's killer. I'm trying I'm
trying to
>> Yeah. It's probably not bothering me
because I don't have headphones. But
yeah, I'm You got to stop that. Please,
brother. Please.
>> Sorry.
>> Cuz once he calls it out, I start
hearing I start noticing it. [laughter]
>> Okay. So, answer that. your your your
Quran needs independent verification
when it comes down to the claim that it
makes about being a part of the
Abrahamic faith, about Muhammad being in
line with the previous scriptures and
being in line with the previous prophets
and also being the seal of the prophets
that came before. You can't just claim
that and say it's true because Muhammad
says so. We need to see this line of of
of truth that connects the old prophets
up into the final one which who you
think is Muhammad. So, how do you
>> That would be the word of God. Through
the word of God.
>> Thank you. So, how do you do that
without going to scriptures you don't
even agree with?
>> Well, that was one verse and one
scripture that I didn't agree with.
>> No, that was two
>> or two. Sorry.
Anything that has anything to do with
>> that's all we need. If we if I prove
that your God is not found within this
book, then that means your God is not in
this book. You don't get to force Allah
into the Old Testament and the New
Testament because you want to. You don't
get to do that.
>> The Jews can use that same argument
against you.
>> I'm not the New Testament.
>> I'm not talking to a Jew. I'm talking to
a Muslim. They're not going to save you
because they don't even believe Jesus is
the Messiah. They're not going to help
you. So, with that being said, argue
like a Muslim. Whatever the Jews say has
nothing to do with you.
>> Well, if the Quran disagrees with the
New Testament and the Old Testament
disagrees with the New Testament,
>> then there's a clear there's a clear
>> You said the Quran disagrees with the
Old Testament.
>> The New Testament and the Old uh the Old
Testament disagrees with the New
Testament also. The New Testament is in
the middle. The Old Testament came
first. The Quran came last. Your your
book is in the middle. Sir,
>> pay attention. No matter how you put it,
your God is not the God of the Torah.
Your God is not the God of the Gospels.
I can prove it both ways. If you want to
split the books in half, which I'm not
going to allow you to do, I can still
prove to you your God is not the God of
the Torah either, just with just with
the verse from the Torah. But I've
already proven to you that your God is
not found within these scriptures, and
you're trying to go to something else.
You need to justify how your God is not
doing the things that that God is doing
in those previous books. Why?
>> Well, well, it's only one book. It's
just the New Testament. That is the
major disagreement is the New Testament.
>> All right. All right, I'll give you
something from the Old Testament then.
Uh, does Allah punish David for
committing adultery?
>> I honestly don't know if I'm being
honest with you, sir.
>> What do you mean?
>> I do not know the answer.
>> Well, I'm not a scholar.
>> Is Is David committing adultery and
being punished by Allah in your Quran?
>> I do not know. I'm sorry.
>> Okay, that's found in the Old Testament.
Okay, that's found in the Old Testament.
Do you believe David committed adultery?
>> If it says he committed adultery and if
it says he was punished for it in the
Old Testament, then I will believe it.
Okay, that's what it says in the Old
Testament. I just want to let you know
before I get the verse. Do you believe
David committed adultery? If I read that
in the Old Testament and it shows David
>> Hi, my phone's dying. I
>> think he said his phone is dying.
>> How did he Your phone is dying or died?
>> I think it probably died just now.
>> Okay. Well,
>> Moses Muslims just can't accept. It's so
weird. Muslims don't like the Bible.
Muslims don't like the Torah. They don't
like the inje. But for some reason, they
can't accept that their god is not
operating in this book. It's so weird.
This is my book. You don't get to come
to it and tell me that Allah is here and
then I show you Allah is not there. And
for some reason, that just can't make
any sense to you. The reason why they do
this, ladies and gentlemen, is because
as a Muslim, they know they need
something. If they don't have anything,
then they know that their religion is
terrible because they don't have
anything to prove what it is they say.
That's why they have a hard time putting
two and two together. Like, oh, Allah
isn't Yahweh. Oh, Allah didn't do these
things in the Torah. Oh, I don't agree
with David committing adultery. Oh, I
don't agree with the things that
happened to Aaron and Moses in the Old
Testament. Because they'll tell you
there are things that that that are in
the Old Testament that they don't agree
with. There are things that are in the
Torah that they don't agree with. There
are stories that are retold in the Torah
that literally does not match with
what's being taken place in the Quran.
But they they they cannot compute that.
They will agree that all of that stuff
is there, but it's corrupted. So
therefore, Allah still gets to remain in
this book. I I I just with that
theology, bro, I just I can't, bro. I
can't personally be a Muslim with that
ideology,